es ist soweit schon sehr bald können wir
in städten mit flug praxen von a nach b
fliegen und sehr bald heißt nicht etwa
in ein paar jahren sondern noch dieses
jahr wo und wann diese menschen drohen
zuerst eingesetzt werden jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
die entwicklung schreitet mit
hochgeschwindigkeit voran immer mehr und
immer besser drohnen fliegen durch die
lüfte in deutschland werden 2020 eine
millionen drohnen unterwegs sein so
schätzt die deutsche flugsicherung aber
es werden noch keine flug taxen sein
oder mindestens nicht so viele
es wird überall daran gearbeitet
geforscht und entwickelt
es hat ein richtiger wettlauf um diese
menschen drohen begonnen und die
chinesen scheinen die nase vorn zu haben
wahrscheinlich werden sie die ersten
sein die den regulären betrieb aufnehmen
aber auch hier in deutschland stehen die
zeichen auf drohnen das deutsche startup
volo will schon 2018 flug taxen in
deutschland einsetzen doch zunächst will
singapur den volo copter so heißt diese
drohne testen die riesige stadt ächzt
unter dem verkehr und singapurs
verkehrsminister parking will drohnen
menschen drohnen einsetzen um den
verkehr in der metropole in den griff zu
bekommen drohnen haben dabei große
vorteile sie verbrauchen deutlich
weniger energie als ein pkw sind viel
schneller am ziel benutzen kürzere
routen und verbrauchen dadurch noch mal
weniger energie und sie verstopfen nicht
die straßenbauer es gibt noch zahlreiche
ungeklärte fragen gibt es hier in
deutschland für solche flug taxi
keinerlei rechtlichen rahmen im
gegenteil städte sind grundsätzlich
erstmals flugverbotszone in die nur mit
genehmigung eingeflogen werden darf die
software die muss so entwickelt werden
dass es keine zusammenstöße gibt es muss
gewährleistet werden dass die drohnen
langen bevor die batterien leer sind und
so weiter und so fort
in dubai ist man zuversichtlich all
diese probleme achtung jetzt kommt bis
zum sommer aus dem weg zum hier sollen
dann die ersten autonomen drohenden
taxen fliegender chinesischer hersteller
hat eine drohne konstruiert die per app
bestellt wird und den fluggast dann zu
dem gewünschten ort transportiert ohne
dass der gast irgendetwas
der flug wird dabei aus einer zentrale
beobachtet und im notfall auch
korrigiert das 184 hiv kann bis zu 30
minuten in der luft bleiben fliegt 160
km/h spitze und hat eine reichweite von
40 bis 50 kilometern die zukunft kommt
eben manchmal schneller als man denkt
wir halten euch natürlich hier über das
thema auf dem laufen wenn er dazu nichts
verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht
mehr an auf die glocke zu geben und wer
bisher liegt nur noch nicht abonniert
hat der hat das verpasst unsere bester
flames draufklicken und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran